the delta airlines women passenger
there's not really much details on how
this started other than i guess this
girl is walking by a guy that didn't
have his mask on and then she told him
to put it on and then
this whole thing happened after me well
what's up
nothing who watch it it's a long well
not that long but
yeah
she has her mask on yeah she has a mask
oh it's underneath her nose yeah that's
frowned upon
not under her chin
telling to stand up she thinks she can
fight it yeah
she's getting knocked out this whole
guy's gonna put something heavy ready
mask up
[ __ ]
watch
he ate that [ __ ] mm-hmm
now is that the trinity killer from
dexter
we'll check after
that
right there
yeah i would have [ __ ] lost it oh
this guy got the coffee cart rolling
though that thing's heavy too
hot
where's his wife i think he's right next
to him
meanwhile hers is [ __ ] at her chin
this chick is out of her mind i don't
know i wish there was a she didn't have
a mask on it i wish there's a big girl
on the flight to [ __ ] her up yeah
someone
but the whole mass covet stuff gives
people this weird like power power now
like weird people that have never had
power before this girl's gonna go to
she's in trouble
oh yeah this is big trouble no we need a
big girl to beat the [ __ ] out of her
the cops had
were ready for her when they uh when
that flight had landed yeah she's [ __ ]
yeah she should be fine totally but also
like to be that aggressive oh no about
people like she'll get sued handcuffed
hand it off to the fbi that's going to
cost her a lot of money
that's like it's in the air it's a
federal whatever offense or something
yeah it's crazier she's going to not be
able to fly the airline it's going to
cost her a [ __ ] she's going to pay a
fine he's going to sue her she's going
to pay a lot of money that's a don just
kept calling her karen which is
hilarious
[ __ ] then she went off on it but also
like you know people say that when they
take airlines they a lot of times
they'll take ambien or something and
they're not in the same frame of mind
you've heard this before right from
other people
she can kiss me i know there's no excuse
charlotte but i wonder if that's just
she'll say that he's a strong man for
taking that spirit i know dude that's
the strongest scratch
there's not much you can do as a man
i would look at my girlfriend
i know right yeah i can't do that i
can't do anything kill her i can't if i
get up and knock her the [ __ ] out what
am i going to do i'm really in trouble
then yeah you know you can't win that
you got to just take you got to eat all
the dicks for a while mm-hmm
she's [ __ ] now because her name's out
and her instagram handles that she
actually should delete it or oh people
are lighting her up lighting her up yeah
because she sucks cairns of the world
feel like they have power now that's
whole yeah you seem to do that to the
wrong person get beat up oh yeah that's
what they they need because because
she's lucky she caught him she should
have been there that'll knock her the
[ __ ] out
yeah
that's what you want a girl to do you
gotta do it yeah